what's up guys bang bang bitcoin had a
massive week this week and so of course
one of the beauties of the market is
that we can go right to the on-chain
data and the macro data and see exactly
what's happening in the bitcoin network
here's a summary of the past week if we
start out we can see right here some of
the key market dynamics the bitcoins
trading just under 39 000
drastically outperforming a number of
different assets if we then go take a
look at the bitcoin network stats
themselves the bitcoin market cap
sitting just about 750 billion dollars
or so of course we're still at one point
seven seven percent inflation rate which
is below the fed's target of two percent
over ninety percent of the bitcoin
supply has now been issued out into the
market into that circulating supply the
real exchange volume at 2.5 billion or
so over a million active addresses and
miners were paid 35.7 million dollars in
the last 24 hours to secure the
decentralized network of bitcoin the
gbtc premium is now a discount at a
negative 25.34
and bitcoin is still down 43 from its
all-time high if we go and we take a
look bitcoin versus gold versus the s p
500 we see that bitcoin over the last
year is down 28
while gold's up seven and the s p 500 is
up two percent but if you go to any
other time period bitcoin is absolutely
destroying gold in the snp up 374 over
the last two years and up 775 000
over the last decade then if we take a
look at bitcoin's closing price bitcoin
sitting right about 39 000 means that
bitcoin has only ever been above this
price point for about 349 days that
means for over 92 percent of bitcoin's
life bitcoin has been lower than the
current price point so if you bought
bitcoin at that point and you held till
today you would be in profit if we then
go ahead and take a look at the compound
annual growth rate of bitcoin over the
last decade it sits at 145 or so
destroying the s p 500 nasdaq gold and
tlt and then of course that five year
sharp ratio at 1.51
coming in much much more attractive than
any other asset then let's switch gears
and go to willy woo willie tweeting out
that the orange coin seems a bit
undervalued here not a bad time for
investors to wait for the law of mean
reversion to play out he's looking at
that highly liquid supply shock
oscillator going ahead and trying to
tell us exactly how much bitcoin is
worth compared to the price at which
it's trading then if we take a look and
we go and run over to will clemente the
wizard himself taking a look on chain at
exactly what's going on in the brand new
block ware newsletter that came out this
week first he starts with the price and
he drew out these lines showing that
bitcoin just trading in range then if we
go ahead and we take a look at the
on-chain price levels what we can see is
that in blue here the short-term holder
cost basis and then in orange a ratio of
realized price liveliness called a
hodler implied price
this is a bullish scenario based on the
chart according to will and ultimately
you'd want to see a push above the
short-term holder cost basis that
they've been talking about the bearish
case would be that we actually go down
and cross over the short term cost basis
before the huddler implied that would be
a sign of capitulation if we then go
ahead and take a look at various price
levels we can see here at the realized
price distribution this visualizes the
amount of bitcoin that was last moved at
each denominated price level about
fourteen percent of bitcoin's money
supply last moved between thirty eight
thousand and forty one thousand dollars
showing that that is the highest
distribution on this graphic then let's
go move and take a look at the funding
rate which remains kind of a mixed
signal it's an indication of a lack of
strong opinion in either direction from
the perpetuals market as well as an
increasing market efficiency that is the
view of the block ware folks then let's
go take a look at the geographic
premiums and will and the blockware team
breaking down this idea that asian
trading hours have been trading bitcoin
at a premium for the first time since
january that's been a fairly strong
signal of local recoveries aside from a
slight premium in late november and then
ultimately the previous premium regimes
the postcovid crash the dip that bought
to 47 000 in april of 2021 a massive dip
buying in the summer of 2021 and then of
course the 40k in september 21 and then
right in january so to see the asian
trading hours trading bitcoin at a
premium pretty incredible then let's
jump to the supply not moved in at least
a year we continue to see an amount over
64
sitting around 64.5
which is an all-time high bitcoiners
aren't selling and over 64 of bitcoin
has not moved in at least a year then
let's jump and take a look at the
bitcoin whale holdings and you can see
that whales are accumulating
aggressively this is such an important
metric that will literally texted it to
me this week and said wow
as we see the entities with over 1 000
bitcoin filtering out all the exchanges
in gbtc etc those whales continue to add
to their holdings this is the first time
since january that we've seen this occur
now of course the bitcoin market it's
important to pay attention to the
on-chain metrics on chain is not some
magical indicator it doesn't tell us the
future but what it does do is it opens
up in a transparent way exactly what's
already happening on chain
this data is available in the bitcoin
market it's like getting an earnings
report every single day on the bitcoin
network the wall street investors are
going to open their eyes and start to
realize that on-chain metrics are
incredibly important and as they begin
to realize they have more information
and more transparency in this industry
you're going to see more and more
investors more and more traders start to
come into the market bitcoin is holding
strong especially in light of the
meltdown in tech stocks and other
industries all those other assets
they're down 50 60 70
bitcoin down about 40 or so and so even
though it's down in price it's holding
up better than lots of other risk assets
it's gonna be interesting to see where
bitcoin goes from here there's arguments
that it could be a bearish outlook
there's arguments that could be a
bullish outlook my favorite metric
though is that 64.5 of bitcoin hasn't
moved in a year this market's illiquid
and it's gonna take a catalyst of demand
to drive the price higher where that
comes from i don't know and neither does
most people but when it comes as we've
seen many many times before
bitcoin moves fast
once it gets going that's it for this
week i hope you guys enjoyed these
updates i'll be back next week with will
on the show i hope that you guys are
enjoying these and i'll talk to you next
weekend hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time